how long do you do this before you quit
the job
i graduate june of 2015 i go to new york
my job starts july of 2015 at morgan
stanley i quit my job september of 2016.
so just over a year it was right after
uh labor day of of 2016
and the reason i quit was
basically austin as i mentioned he's two
years younger and he had
had his junior year internship he got an
offer to work in investment banking and
he now had to make a decision basically
two years after me was he going to go
full-time into investment banking or do
morning brew like there's a clear fork
in the road it was a fork in the road of
we're either gonna go full time on this
thing or we're not and if we don't go
full time on this thing like this is
it's either gonna
stop
or it's gonna just be kind of like a
shell of itself and so it was very much
like this was an inflection point and we
decided to go full time on it
and i i think we had different reasons
for going full time on it and for me
the reason i went full time
was a few fold i thought about things in
terms of regret what would i regret more
would i more regret staying at morgan
stanley
and seeing
someone create effectively their version
of morning brew and it succeeding
or would i more regret
leaving morgan stanley doing morning
brew and morning brew fails and i have
to find a new job
and to me the answer was obviously when
i answered that question which is i
would far more regret staying at morgan
stanley and seeing someone succeed with
their version of morning brew just
because they
risked their time when when i wouldn't
that was the first way i thought about
it the second way i thought about it was
what is the worst case scenario so i
thought i always use things as like the
worst case scenario framework in a
decision and can you live with the worst
case scenario and the worst case
scenario was i quit my job i work on
morning brew and then
say six months later it fails because
the vast majority of businesses fail and
then i was like then what what would
have happened in that worst case
scenario and i said
first maybe morgan stanley would take me
back because i had this entrepreneurial
experience that made me
maybe
made me
unique in my experience
and uh they would value that and i would
say i said no let's say that's the worst
case scenario and i burned my bridges
and they wouldn't take me back then what
it was like maybe this makes a good
business school story where i could
apply to business school and i said you
know what
maybe uh this is a common story and it
would get me into business school and i
said maybe
um i
met other people while i was doing this
startup in the startup scene and i could
go start another company or join an
early stage company and i basically got
like four or five layers deep of options
and i was like if none of these are
options
after morning brew fails
that this isn't actually like a morning
brew problem this is an alex problem of
not keeping his options open as a
professional and so that was the second
way i looked at it and the third way i
looked at it was simply about how do i
want to live my life it sounds cliche
but
i very much you know i just had like a
mentally transformative experience where
a week before junior year of college at
michigan
my dad passed away suddenly uh he passed
away
from a stroke he was 49 years old he was
perfectly healthy like literally built
the same as me
uh
similar uh physical health
and after that experience everything
just became clearer around
one how most things that we worry about
on a daily basis in life are wildly
unimportant
and two
how
really like you know your your time on
your uh life countdown clock you have no
idea when it's going to hit zero you
look at the statistics and you hope that
it's gonna hit zero around you know 80
years old or later but you really have
no idea and basically i said to myself
if if i knew my countdown clock was
hitting zero tomorrow
what would i rather be doing with my
time and it was like a no-brainer it was
like i knew that i was so
more so far more enjoying the experience
of building my own thing and tinkering
like i was tinkering in kindergarten
than sitting in front of a computer
screen and trading mortgages hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day